e
y
so we we just got word that some people
did go to the lottery so we'll wait a
few minutes to start waiting a few
minutes
e
we're going to call the meeting the
order
um only only one missing is Aaron and
Charlie will be here less than a half
hour
so
um we're going to start with the pledge
Tim you want to lead us pled right
here I pledge allegiance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all thank
you um everyone make sure you use your
microphones for the audience to hear
when we when you're speaking um uh I
need a motion on on the minutes so moved
written as
presented second okay any discussion Mr
chair yes um I was here and I'm not
listed as being here okay we'll we'll
correct that thank you and that so the
motion is going to be as as
corrected uh okay sorry about
that all right um so all in favor of the
minutes as as amended I all opposed none
okay minutes
approved all right so now we're going to
start the process of what we're going to
put in our final report we uh we still
have one piece that we're going to be
hearing from probably next meeting on
the uh problem gaming um issue but uh
given I'm the the person's going to have
to write the report I need I need input
from everybody on what issues uh we want
to um for number one there a couple
things we're going to say that we
discussed and that whether or not we
come to agreement on on a resolution or
not is something that will as we go
along either we're going to all agree on
something or not agree on something
that's fine it'll be in the report we
didn't agree we talked about it or that
we it needs further consideration uh
would be probably a third category so
that's that's where I want to go but
what I want to started with is on the 40
page 42 of the report I'm going to
emphasize this where we came from and
it's still in our statutes and I said
this last meeting on page
42 the of the uh Spectrum
report they they talked about the RSA a
gaming a game operator employer is
defined as a business entity or
individual who employs
supervises and controls game operators
and who was hired by a charity
organization to operate games of chance
on its behalf on its behalf we've come a
long way since then and what that meant
was that those facilities these
facilities would open up when there was
a charity who wanted to have a casino
night at their location and it's evolved
now to where we have two large casinos
about to be built one in ashaa and now
it looks like the Salam one it sounds
like I read in the union leader so it
sounds like it's pretty much there the
um the uh um Joe faroh uh place in in uh
Salem and these These are quite large as
well uh both of those are pretty large
so uh still not full for casinos that
you would find in other states but but
large by our
standards so um so thus here we are as a
commission uh have to address a bunch of
issues so we're going to start with I
have two documents that you was you were
were sent and one was the was our
um was the Statute that created the
commission and there's five points that
we were supposed to cover and then I
have my other list because um I think
the Spectrum report brought up some
issues that we we be nice if we could
take opinion on I'm planning another
three meetings this meeting and then
three more then we run out of time the
last meeting we're going to have to
approve the report so between now and
mid-
October uh I'll be drafting a report uh
that
obviously send that ahead of time in
that last meeting we're going to have to
agree on that report and we can make
modifications on it and I'll agree that
we would send a if we meet on Mondays we
have until the end of that week to to
get the report in so if you go to the
the original charges I'm going to do the
I'm going to do the two easy ones
first um this the Third charge was
whether charging rented Charities is
necessary with historic
racing and I think the legislator has
already figured that one out so I'm I'm
going to ask for a vote that we are in
agreement with what the legislature has
done and doing away with rent as is is
any discussion on that before we we talk
about it no so um so I would say
something in the report that the uh the
legislature um and both bodies s signed
to law um was agreed to do away with the
rent and I'll probably put some other
text in there to as to why uh but um so
can we take a vote on that as members
please um so all in favor of of agreeing
with what the legislature had
done can I all opposed none okay so
that's that's one that we agree
on chair that's the removal of rents
removal of rents and that charge is now
disposed of that charge is disposed of
exactly that's what I was trying to do
that's disposed of we're agreeing with
what the legislature had done they took
action before this commission finished
its work so and we agreed with the
action of the legislature so uh number
four uh which is kind of halfway down
the commission also shall monitor the
benefits of historic horse racing to
Charities to ascertain whether
additional licenses for historic ra
horse racing machines would increase or
reduce Revenue to Charities I think the
question is did it increase or reduce
revenues clearly it increased revenues
does anybody think that revenues weren't
increased I think we went through this
we've seen the steady growth in the
revenues and obviously it's tributable
to the historic racing machines I mean
if that's the question um um I'm I'm
look at you Tim was that was that the
intent of that question in the legisl in
the legislation is
again when we pass this bill the idea
was looking at what the gross revenues
were looking like whether Charities due
to the change in the split between games
of chance and now HHR did that result in
more or less money to Charities and I
think the overwhelming answer is more
money to char more Char right so um so
the what what what will appear in the
report is that and I could probably give
some hard numbers in there too um
because I we've been looking at this for
a while that the the that the uh
revenues have increased substantially
since historic racing machines obviously
obviously any
growth in and we're having a lot of
growth now um the Charities there's
going to be a lot more money in the pot
for Charities uh uh going forward so uh
yes guess I took this um question
here which is
it starts out one way and it ends
another is yeah and and the ascertain is
is whether additional licenses for
historical horse racing machines would
increase or reduce revenues to Charities
well I think that's I've been thinking
that that was uh a question of
whether whatever it is 18
licenses are enough or there should
there be more right and I not sure that
that's what I'm hearing you
say well that's because it depends on
how you read this read this
charge because then at the end this
increase I I have that on my other list
do we do we think
that do we could talk about it here as
well uh do we think that the 19
licenses
is not enough too little what and it's
not
only again it's the licenses for the
number of of char of historic r ing
locations and this is the intent here
but and as well we should talk about
number of locations
period um as chair I'm I you know it
it's not just the number of facilities
it's really also I want to talk about
later it's really the number of of uh uh
historic racing machines
themselves you know they're saying that
we can we we have in the report and I
have it later on we talk about it that
we we're just scratching the surface of
be we can put a lot more of these
machines in and
still uh there's the market for it is
what what they said in the Spectrum
report so yeah I'm one for saying well
let's break again so again I think we we
addressed this in the legislature by put
the moratorium on for S years so then
the understanding being we would then
reevaluate and see where we are and
what's going on are we hitting the 6,000
machines that the Spectrum says what
should be the next action that the
legislature takes so you know again I
think the the revenue side we dealt with
um yes there's an increase to revenue to
Charities due to HHR but then the second
question was should we allow more
licenses we've allowed for uh amount of
expansion to occur over the next few
years uh with the five applic that are
pending um but we also said we want to
pause there for that seven years after
that and then we can reevaluate um we
don't know what the industry is going to
look like in seven years what
consolidation might look like who's
going to be still alive in seven years
in terms of which op operations are in
in operation so I I think we dealt with
that by putting the pause in and giving
SE a seven-year window um to freeze this
until we can look at it again um with
new data with more more um operations
possibly open doing HHR um but for us to
try to figure out what 19 19 operations
are going to look like when we only have
10 of the 19 I think operational with
HHR um we don't have a full set of data
so the so we could say that the that in
the report we can say that we agree with
the
legislature uh I just want to make sure
that the commission is agreeing that 19
was the right number
um it was the existing 14 plus this
potential
five uh and I personally don't have a
problem with the
19 um I just want to hear from anybody
is that disagrees with the 19 and we
understand that it's a seven seven-year
moratorium above above 19 although the
legisl can change that any any time they
want uh but uh but again we have to
weigh in on that that we we felt that I
think we'd like to say as a commission
that we felt it needed to be a pause as
well uh to to see what we have here um
and and you know the law says it's it's
19 so we'll go with the 19 uh but you
know going forward yeah I guess we have
to have some time to to evaluate uh what
the Market's going to look like in seven
years from now B yeah I I think it's as
simple as the rent issue it's dealt with
in
legislation all right pretty simple our
opinions on anything don't matter for as
commission members us want anybody to
weigh in that they they agree with what
the legislature has done or not done so
Pat I would say after five years you
probably should put a a note in there
saying there should be another
permission established to see what the
mature uh Market looks like and whether
any future changes are
needed right yes go ahead T dick
yeah yeah thank you um I agree with that
and I I think that um that it it
is good to put into this report that
it's not just because the legisl passed
this moratorium this seven years St say
we think it makes sense in the
circumstances and it also means that
five years from now or whatever um that
the uh legislature needs to consider
the next step
right okay so we agree and that that it
needs to be examined in the future once
again we'll say five years um and and
we'll go from there uh yes John yeah I
mean I would agree with that as well
because we don't have all the data we
only have 10 now I mean it's there's no
way we're going to see into the future
and know that so the 5 years to
reevaluate mix perfect
sense I I I think it does make sense in
this context right now we know that
under under construction are two Mammoth
facilities they're not even an operation
as we speak we have a third one the
Conway situation which is under the
construction so it's not operational as
we speak we have the sandborn situation
which has not been settled that's
hanging out over us is there another
license available you know is there a
license available for
conquer and who's going to make the
Attorney General's involved in that the
Lottery Commission is involved all of
these things are hanging out there you
know as as as we speak so this this
momentum for for growth is is is there
this situation with regard to cker it it
is there those things have to be have to
be resolved
uh as as we move forward they got to be
in
place you're all said if youed you're
going to look at how things are going
and I think we have we as a commission
have to have to Define what is a
casino what is a casino is it a
charitable gabing facility that could be
called a casino because of the way it it
operates I mean it it there's got to be
something in law that governs what we're
what we're looking at and and what we're
evaluating as we as we move forward
again we're we're still we're still
working on the that's the reason I read
page
42 of the of the report that language is
still in there it's that language is
that the Charities are in the driver's
seat that was always the Charities are
always in the driver's seat that's not
the case anymore they're not in the
driver's seat I don't think well I I I
to a certain extent I disagree again
they don't have a charity to operate
they don't operate right so the charity
charity is still in charge of you know
they they they the Charities control
what whether they open their doors or
not which I would say puts them in the
driver's seat um if there's not a
charity available um
so we have the reverse problem the
word's out everybody wants in yeah so so
again I think they're still in the
driver's seat the question is uh around
the revenue stuff we talked about
earlier but um the other thing I want to
Mr chair the number two item which is
whether the state should limit the
number I was going to get there I just
want to finish one of I said know was
the second half of the HHR question
right we kind of limited nobody's going
to open a a games of chance location at
least not a s a big one um without HHR
and since we have a moratorium on HR
we've already put a a default DEA facto
limit on the number of charitable gaming
operations you might see I mean Chasers
which is the outlier I think right
Chasers was a poker room and yet it made
a significant amount of money um just
doing poker and you might see something
like that open up but again it's not the
HHR proliferation that we're talking
about so you know I think we've already
dealt with number two as well with the
moratorium um and I don't know that we
have let's come back to that as a motion
at the end after we do this one let's
finish uh so what we're saying is that
we agree with well one clarifying
thought so basically we're talking about
the the HHR license is and like we said
not every facility has one and or wants
one most that are in the business are
eventually going to get there but some
of the smaller ones you're realizing
there's a certain risk involved in that
and they may or may not go in that
direction
um but I'm I lost my thought now so but
anyway we we we I guess the motion is
going to be that we um we agree with
what the legislature has done in this in
this
moratorium uh and that it should be
evaluated out in the future perhaps 5
years I'll say uh as to you know again
to see what the environment looks like
in the future so are we all agreeing to
that is there any other comment
discussion on
that NOP okay so all in favor of
something like that we'll probably go
through these again when I have the
final report you're going to see actual
words and you can you you can
agree prelim just preliminary for me to
move forward writing something so is
everybody all in favor of that say I I
I'll oppose no okay obain obain okay I'm
sorry I will do obain now sorry it's
just policy questions like that sort
right so um so then let's go back up to
the second bullet there whether the
state should Implement a limit on the
number of uh uh number of travel gaming
ations and and and um and Tim's Tim's
point was probably well taken you know
if they're gonna if someone new is going
to come in they're going to want what's
attracting everybody is historic racing
if we didn't have historic racing none
of these big companies would be here
none of them I mean uh the only one that
took a at least the brook took a risk
assuming that someday that we'd have
slot machines or something uh but uh but
all these big companies are in now um
and I I don't see anybody else moving in
um and the environment is changing it's
you're going to have big guys and small
guys and the big guys are going to you
know they'll they'll probably have more
attractions other reasons to to to go to
these
um so I I guess so what would the motion
be for this Tim Mr the second one so I
would put that the the actions of the
legislature in the previous term
limiting the number of HHR licenses have
de facto uh limited the number of
locations for the next seven years
um and that no no recommendation would
be made to make any changes yes the only
thing I'd say again is the one thing I
was when we talk about this the other
thing you got to remember is that we
started this commission I don't the data
we were using originally was there's
only seven or seven uh HHR licenses held
now it's up to 10 um because of people
coming online so
again all of this conversation has been
around HHR I don't think anybody's heard
complaints about game regular games of
chance type of Charity so again the
table game stuff um and so I I don't
know that we have to limit that at all
there's been no discussion but that's
the problem um so to speak so I don't
think we should limit games of chance
operators the limit is on HHR which is
the more concerning issue around problem
gaming and and and expansion yeah I
think the language
was originally when it was still
eligible for HR so I think it's no
longer right so so give given the fact
that we've limited HHR we don't we
should not put restrictions on the
number of games of chance licenses
okay you all said exact same okay all
right so and given that the environment
has changed and since the the period of
time that this commission's been in in
place uh we feel that there should be no
limit on the the number of travel gaming
locations uh if a small one opens up in
some local some small local with some
table games uh we're okay with that is
what I'm hearing but again G given the
fact that we've um paused HHR licensing
right right so that's the reason why
we're not re making recommendations for
changes in number of games a chance yeah
nothing negates an applicant going to
lottery today or wherever and filing an
application right we shouldn't limit
that right okay all right uh then with
that general idea uh all in favor of
that kind of a motion
I against abstain abstain okay again
we're going to go through these once I
had the final report with the actual
words uh all right right so we did One
two
rent then number five the last one the
commission well go ahead well we have
number one which is split into two
pieces how Charities are selected and
should the process be uniform what list
are we going through this is off of the
charge of the committee oh the charge of
the committee charge of the committee
yeah we making sure we answer those
first before we get
into as I blocked them out there was
like uh there was like five charges
so I I jumped to the easier ones first
and then then the first one was the
commission shall examine how Charities
are selected and whether a uniform
process should exist if if you want to
do the F the last one I have a
recommendation the revenue the host
Community Revenue split oh yeah let's do
that let's do that one first so the
commission shall examine whe whether
host Community shall share in proceeds
of any charal gaming establishment okay
that was in the legisl legislation as
well
uh but the way it's structured now
they're never going to get any money
because there's so many Charities that
are the way the law is now is that only
if there's an open
date uh with the with the Charities uh
and there's no Open dates so go ahead no
again I I agree the the way the uh it
was it was set up was again the last
thing we wanted to do is have government
bump a charity um for the purpose of
Revenue um and so therefore again the
the core function of the operation is
charitable gaming um and so the uh we
felt Charities had first priority over
the government before the government got
it took more money so um so I
don't there there's um so we can do that
we can leave it the way it is and again
reality is that there's no real function
to it because there's always a wait list
there's always somebody in queue from a
charity to go forward so it's non it's
dysfunctional though it does doesn't
have any any function to actually pass
the law to do that um other than on the
off chance a charity you have a SK you
have something on the schedule and a
charity drops out closes its doors
before their date comes up you could
drop a municipality in if you ran into
that situation where a charity closed up
its doors you got your three month I
think G you said it's three months out
roughly is what you do for
Charities yes it's recently changed that
we can extend it out like past that I
believe Charlie or Val could confirm I
think it used to be because of
background checks but we can extend out
past that to we're all looking the valve
yeah so the question was um how far out
can they schedule Charities as a gaming
op it used to be the 60 months it used
to be 60 days but I think because it was
you wanted the background checks for the
Charities but those got eliminated so I
think it's like I don't know how far out
and you want to make sure the charity is
in good standing too at the same time so
so by leaving it the way it is what we
have now with Charity as the first go if
unoff chance of Charity dropped out
after already being scheduled you could
drop the municipality in to our
knowledge since the law passed is any
municipality gotten any dates I would
doubt it it's too
new too question for charity so so if
there's a 60-day requirement does that
mean if that 60-day requirement is not
met they can't dial in another
charity no we usually find a way there's
been times when they haven't met that
okay I just I I don't I don't want to
run into a scenario where a charity
didn't get cleared out 60 days and and
we start dialing municipalities into
that I'm not I'm not a fan this is
charitable gaming I remember it's only
once every 12 months right so even if
one it's only one charity one time a
year if gets dropped off they could fill
a municipality in but then that
municipality's got its 10 days it
doesn't get any more days they can get
one day they can get one day or two days
at a time if yeah they could do that
it's more like a recommendation too it
used to be you couldn't book out past 60
days because the background check they
want to make sure that was good at that
time and nothing changed and now it's
like they recommend at least 68 just so
you have wiggle roam like if they're not
in good standing with charitable trust
because they forgot to file for the year
right but I don't think that process is
broken all right that there's plenty of
wiggle room time to to so that's that's
that's I'm just fores seeeing the
ramifications of I I wasn't a fan of
this legislation to begin with and the
ramifications of this if a municipality
gets dialed into days the legisl has
already spoken about Charities for years
this is charitable gaming all right
let's put this we should have the
Charities taken president so as a
commission let's forget about what the
law was Mr chair yes yes um
yeah I uh we're talking about the uh
certainties and uncertainties of uh
having an opportunity for municipalities
to get some money by getting days um and
the question is whether municipalities
should uh get money period yes that's in
my mind which is a little bit different
and then how do they get it is the
second question so right um on the first
question question my my concern is that
we seem to be headed towards some big
gaming
establishments and uh back uh 10 years
ago or 12 years ago Senator dandre will
maybe remember um we uh with that gaming
commission we're looking at a very big
casino and one of the big questions was
um what did the town it was expected it
would be Salem but uh you know nobody
said that except everybody said it um
and uh uh what would they need to deal
with the public safety issues that uh
fell with hosting a a big casino and
maybe that's what we're headed for here
so I think it's a very legitimate
question I don't have the answer what
should be allocated and how it should be
allocated and maybe there's an argument
that property tax revenues uh from from
the presence of a big facility like this
and it's uh uh related facilities uh
take takes care of the question um you
know we should have that discussion or
if we're not able to do it with the
information we have we should flag it as
a question for future consideration by
the
legislature good yeah I I think uh
represent Ames is correct the situation
was as it as the entities grew what what
was the responsibility of the
municipality in terms of containing it
yet we we discussed paring problems
talked about security problems all all
of these entities coming together when
you thought when you had a lot a very
large facility and who would bear the
responsibility uh for that was it the
entity itself or the municipality and a
lot of discussion about the municipality
and and the cost of inur that's going to
have to be looked at as as we move
forward when you look at the the size of
the shable gaming operations that we're
talking we're talking about as as as U
as I see it at this at this moment in
time you we are we are somebody's
considering basically four large
facilities now you're talking about
100,000 square ft
you're talking about nasua Salem
Rochester and conquered these these
haven't been these haven't been
constructed yet and we how big is your
Conway the one in Conway is pretty small
so that's
under square footage under I believe
15,000 square feet so so what we've what
we've seen with these new ones is is the
fact of the matter that someone is going
to have to support these these entities
and if they're in a
municipality located within a a district
in that municipality somebody is going
to have to uh support the the items that
they they're requesting and we spent a
lot of time talking about that and we
did we we always talked about a
percentage going to the local
municipality in in order to sustain that
so uh I think as these as as these
things
grow these things are going to have to
be considered by a few you're talking
about it was part of the gross Gaming
revenue the the the gross number small
percentage of the gross rate we talked
about that in the in those discussions
there were there were many ways of doing
it but that was one of the things do you
remember that is that I don't remember
exactly what the number was yeah maybe
you do Charlie yeah I think it was three
to the community that hosted and then 1%
shared by
joining that's right something like that
wait wait 3% of 3% of the gross revenues
3% of yeah of the gross so it was
essentially be like three million a year
would have been Salem and then a joining
Community shared a million yeah
were based on those revenues Aaron first
Aaron and yeah I just want to mention
there have been and will be
opportunities for cities to have their
input heard and get something out of the
casino you know for instance the one in
nashwa the Nash they had to get Planning
and Zoning um lot the one they're
proposing in Salem same thing they're
going through City hearings we've in
Dover we had to agree to certain things
to get zoning orces so the city want it
um off duty police there so all the
communities are getting for the most
part their say in these larger
developments so it's not like they don't
have any they don't get a share of the
revenue but they could ask for it in
some of these mes I think just it it the
nature the nature the process has grown
dramatically and and as a result of that
the planning operations in the in in the
community the zoning operations in the
community they all have to be considered
because we're talking about something
more than just the church Hall you know
on Tuesday
night that there's a lot more that's now
com come into play
that those things are happening someone
mentioned that they will be paying
property tax you know that's kind of a
footprint let's say 100,000 square feet
uh but I think the norm is that
that we should have had Spectrum this
the norm is that that the facilities
will pay a little extra for security
it's not your average business this this
this business is going to be open till
what 3:00 or 4 in the morning uh aren't
here yet um but there's there's extra
police um presence I think that that
we're talking about really more than
anything else um so I I I guess the way
to handle it is that number one that do
we agree that there should be some
additional
payment and I guess by the facilities
and I I'm I'm I kind of hesitated
3% um we don't have to agree to the
exact number it this moment but uh but
big picture-wise is it is it should the
Charities we may not all agree on this
so should the uh
facilities pay uh an increment of let's
just say gross gaming
revenues 3% seems really high um but um
let's have that discussion real quick
Tim so so again M the nowhere in this
commission we was there actually any
data presented that says that this
business creates any more Public Safety
or other issues than any other business
in a community um a restaurant and a bar
you know that's a large sports bar
probably has more calls to service for
law enforcement than a a than a gaming
facility does in this modern Market that
we have now so I want to be careful
about H creating this this idea that you
know the day of the CD casino and having
unsavory characters are a little bit
different than what we have now um and
that I don't think that there was no
data anywhere in any conversation
whether in this commission or in my or
in my ways of Means Committee on when we
were talking about Revenue sharing um
was uh there I want to remind I think uh
someone brought it up that all of these
facilities have to go through site
planning review so you talk about
parking they have the same restrictions
as any site plan review for any other
business they have a number of parking
spaces they need there's health and
safety concerns that they that are
lighting concerns you know lots of
things I think in the case of Rochester
they were actually talking about actual
uh Aesthetics of the place that was was
of concern than being dealt with so
again I think municipalities have a huge
amount of impact as to how that is
handled and I'll remind you know again
that like every other business in town
they pay property taxes if there's a
water sewer district they pay for the
water and sewer they use there's a fire
district they pay part of the fire
district so all of these things that are
added taxes based on the evaluation of a
community of of a building are paid to
the community me into the community
already to alleviate taxes and I just
haven't seen any data that says that
these facilities create a a a
disproportionate amount of service
requests that increase cost for
municipalities uh so so I just want to
be careful that we don't go we don't you
know say that now that being said I'm
also in favor of taxpayer relief and so
if we can find if there are days that
we're going to be unused and we are
bumping a charity then we can give that
to the municipality and that would be
unexpected revenue from the municipality
that they could use to help lower
property and give property tax relief to
the local communities that's the reason
why the bill was put forward the way it
was was we didn't want to bump Charities
but we did want to have the opportunity
to maybe have taxpayer relief if there
was an availability within a in a
facility so for me I I'm not a big I I I
would I don't mind it if we can do it as
taxpayer relief not as dedicated funds
and and like like I said in the way we
structured that bill that was the idea
that it would be unexpected income to
the community that would result in prop
property taxpayer relief the the other
thing is
uh a lot of these especially the larger
ones do have Security on the inside that
they pay for your facilities oh yeah
right we we have 247 Security on our
property do you have camera you have
know inside the casino there's cameras
everywhere how about in the parking lot
do you have cameras in the parking lot
yes do but I don't know if that's a
requirement right I'm saying we have
like 24/7 security officers like on our
premise at all times right um another
thing I mean I feel like we're going a
little out of scope I think we should
leave it up to the municipalities
because you do have to get a license
from them as well and they can make
requirements we've even requested like a
resource officer Hut um but
unfortunately even if we were to give
money I think the main concern talking
about is more police presence and we
hire police details when we can we even
supported leg legislation locally to
increase their pay which 100% comes out
of our pocket it goes to to pay the
detail of course and then there's a
little extra to pay the city there's
some taxes um but so it there's a
shortage on police officers so even if
we dump more money into it I'm not
confident it would equal more police
presence do you saying your security is
detailed we do we hire police details
when we can they don't
always and it's a volunteer just to that
point that municipalities uh are in
charge of that I know Salem has put put
requirements in relation to police
details at the room that's present so I
mean as far as that
goes it sounds like the issue more and
more I'm hearing here is that that
municipalities through the their
licensing process for these facilities
are probably making certain requests of
the
facilities to have to have certain
security
coverage uh paid for by the
facility um the question is do we really
need to weigh in on this now uh it
sounds like dick go ahead yeah my my
feeling is um
is that I would not want to support I
would not support a a um a
recommendation that uh said um that came
out against any provision for um
allocation of revenues to host
communities or borderline communities
however you want to describe it to the
area um for a special costs that arise
um I would not want to support a
categorical uh rejection of that
Prospect I I can support flagging the
issue saying it's an issue the
commission discussed there are various
ways to address this including uh what
we what has been talked about here and
um and uh it may be a subject that
warrants future legislation and leave it
at that yeah
okay I I think that might be the
solution to this to get unanimity um on
this um okay so let's what dick just
said probably covers it all so no
recommendation recommend future study if
if legure feels its per right and I just
want to if I may respond uh to one thing
Senator Lang said
um is is true we haven't discussed this
we we haven't heard information about
issues in
this uh uh on this matter but um that's
really because we didn't ask for it
didn't get centered uh we didn't ask
Spectrum to tell us what other places
around the country do on this and um we
didn't yes we didn't specifically ask
them to do that and it wasn't in their
report
so yeah thank you all right uh so we'll
take a quick vote here all in favor of
of not making a specific recommendation
on this but that we should leave the
door open for the future uh that it
should it should be looked at in the
future is that okay so all I'm favor of
that say I I I'll oppos abstain okay
thank you all right so that leaves us
with one left on this list
um I lost where I was here
number one
we they're selected whe should be yeah
number one so you know I've tried to
bring this up all along uh We've we've
had some discussion on
it
uh is there a uniform process I would
say no we leave it up to the facilities
to other than that what the law says up
to 10 days so they can give up to 10
days they can do five five55 they can do
fil one or two but maximum of 10
days and the way they pick the Charities
because I've talked to some other owners
as well on this and it sounds like
there's different points of view on this
and I don't think correct me if I'm
wrong anywhere in the statutes that we
actually give guidance to how to pick
these Charities other than other than
the number of days that that they can
and they have to pass the the charity
has to make we have to make sure that
they're a legitimate
charity um and is it a year is it no
that's the wrong one it's not a year
waiting time they they can do it and
once they're approved they're
approved
um and again my my bigger issue is is
now we're up to you know the brook
everybody's getting about 150,000 plus a
year uh places that are large or these
we're getting to a point where what the
limit should be uh if there should be a
limit uh it's it's all success I mean
this success has brought this
on um but some point you're going to say
that we need three Charities instead of
two you know when the when the Nash
opens and when this other place opens
this is not this discussion isn't really
for the smaller places it's really for
the larger places
where the payouts you know charity is
going to get
300,000 uh but but but underlying all of
that is is there uniformity of course
the question is is there
process well not really and tell me I'm
wrong someone tell me I'm wrong that
there isn't a uniform process let's
start there goad so again breaking it
down into two pieces right there's two
questions answered in that first
questions asked in that first charge the
first question is how they're selected
and they're selected by the local gaming
operator um based on application right
whoever whoever applies right they come
in they put an application in sometimes
uh they will uh go and and Chase it op G
uh charity but um but it's basically
it's an application process based on
first come first serve who shows up they
go fill out the application and then uh
they're put in the queue so I think the
the the first question is on on the how
it's selected is it's selected by the uh
local gaming operator whether or not we
think that's appropriate or not is the
first question right and the result and
the results of that the second question
is um given that it's it that process
occurs do we want uniformity amongst all
gaming operators on how they select a
charity right is the second question um
so I'm I'm completely okay with the
local gaming operators picking their
Charities um again there's C there's a
certain aspect of I'm not sure why we
would require um Gate City casino to do
the Berlin little league as a
requirement um there there's no
geographical connection it doesn't make
sense it no input there's no way the the
Berlin little league is going to
advertise for its members to go running
down to Nashua to participate in gaming
so there's not even any cross
promotional aspect to it so I'm okay
with having with having local operators
uh choose do I think there should be a
more uniform process in the second half
of that question I think the answer is
yes and I'm not sure that there's
legislative requirements needed to do
that um it could be as much as a rules
like hey Lottery can issue the form
here's the charity form I don't know if
they do that already um but here's the
forms that the Charity's got to fill out
to and and the process for making that
happen um so and make sure that all the
operators follow the same exact process
for doing that so I think the revenue
conversation is a completely different
conversation and I want to take that
outside the charge of the of the um of
of the uh committee and if it's a
recommendation beyond the charges of the
committee let's take that Revenue split
conversation about three Charities two
Charities $100,000 $775,000 what's the
number yeah and I and so and I've
already said in these meetings that
we're probably going to need more time
on that one um that the recommendation
and we'll handle this later on the
recommendation may be that that there be
another commission just to look at that
because there's a lot of there's going
to be a lot that goes into that um
that's all about the numbers so
um all right so this one is
um Mr chair yeah
one one question I would just ask the
committee and just popped into my head
is should is so right now the law limits
up to two only two Charities Max is that
true yes um and do we want to
potentially recommend that that Max be
hard because I know one of the qu one of
the concerns you had was that sometimes
little you felt like little league was
getting too much it was Way Beyond what
you thought they
needed and then the question becomes do
operators
hesitate working with small Charities
because now they think okay well it
doesn't really make sense for this
charity to get this huge amount of money
do we up the number of recommended let
the charity decide they can have up to
maybe four I'm just throwing a number
I've not thought about it maybe up to
four or five so that they're less likely
to say well I don't want to just have
one or two small Charities but maybe
there's a group of Charities that
somehow I'm just thinking off the C this
this is a this is a we're not going to
have time to come to that conclusion I
mean I went through this remember I sent
this around we we talked about this a
while ago you know Youth Sports 55 of
the Charities are youth
Sports uh Lions Club had 31 the
different Lions Clubs public libraries
had
19 uh religious organizations had 18 I
mean I can go through you know it's all
over the place but not all the are
created equal I mean they're not all uh
we call them Charities first off that's
a misnomer it's it's it's not for profit
organizations it's not charitable or
they're not for-profit
organizations I mean it's a misnomer the
titling of the whole thing I mean it's
charal gaming uh but a lot of these
organizations will like L all the
various clubs they they they raise money
for other organizations we understand
that that are true charities
um
so with that said I think yeah there's
there's definitely a problem coming I I
talked about the Nash they showed the
numbers on the
Nash that that you know pretty soon two
two two would not is not going to be
enough or or or these Charities when 10
days are going to get
300,000 now maybe there's some that that
are worthy of getting 300,000 but you
know there it's it's and again it's we
we're really into the mode of big places
now and little places there's total two
different discussions the little places
are probably okay the way we're doing
things the bigger places I don't know
we're we're really I don't think there's
enough time for us to address the second
part of the of Tim's question because it
becomes it's a difficult one believe it
or not you know we got we got more
Charities lining up wanting to be
involved how do we get them
involved uh one way is to cap that
because we know the revenue is going to
grow especially in the big places
um and then and then and then then means
more Charities now you can do it in
different ways you could have a third
charity or you could just say okay
someone has to make a
decision that this is really a charity
and this one is well I don't know you
know why why does the you know the
public library gets public money but the
public libraries have 19 of these that
are that are probably have a foundation
or something around them as well uh how
much do they need do they need another
150 for a small town Library probably
not um so we have to somehow um come up
with a way of
categorizing these Charities and that's
that's that'll take a long time to do I
tried to at least show what we have now
but to say who's who's Worthy is not
worthy becomes a problem to try to
say um you know any division it's
probably easier to do it in the uniform
way
you know it takes the
because certainly don't want the
individual charal locations to to be
involved in coming up with their own
rules on this either no looking at your
list again and when you mentioned again
uh Town operations a lot of them again
if you want are
auxiliaries like libraries Friends of
the library they are they are not
Municipal um if you want no I understand
that I know that they're friends of and
all that right yeah right and they're
fundraising to get more books or
whatever more reading room or whatever
you know we understand that
so so regarding the first charge again
how how Charities is selected I think
the recommendation can just be that uh
Charities are currently selected locally
by the gaming operators um and that that
that works well for the Charities
because it creates a geographical and a
community of interest for the Charities
that are local to that to that gaming
operation and that should be our first
you can I pause you right there so in
the historic racing Bill we we put some
language about um and it's a it's it's a
not a
shall it's a should I think that if they
can find local
charities they get preference but they
can still invite other charities in if
right it's making sure we understand
that right and I and I and again I think
that's working I think that's working
the way it should it's done by local and
that and it's about the local it's
really by U uh what do you call it
districts the five U ex coun right which
I don't know it's kind of those
districts are kind of funny so I don't
know why we picked that but you know in
terms of some go from one end of the
state to the other uh so I'm just trying
to again number one how they're selected
locally and is with with an eye towards
um being Geographic and and of local
community interest and then the second
half is should the process be uniform
and my an I think the committee's answer
should be yes and that Lottery should um
Sorry Charlie Charlie's head just
snapped up really fast um that Lottery
should should review that and see what
and take a deeper dive into how that
looks and whether or not it needs to be
a regulatory or legislative solution to
create a uniform process so that Nash is
doing the same thing that Conway's doing
in the selection I think to relieve of
Charlie of having to deal with that is
that I think I think we need I think we
need to have another commission just to
look at that
specifically but I'm not talking about
the revenue side I'm strictly talking
about why am I picking charity you know
what what process right this talks about
process what's the process for charity a
what's the process for Charity B and why
would I pick charity a versus Charity B
and what do they both go through the
same process in order to get selected
the simple process not I think number
six on your thing is all about the
revenue and that and the size and scope
and whether you have small Charities or
large Charities and what that looks like
I think
is a future but I think just for this to
make sure that there's a consistent
process from One gaming operator to
another on the selection to make sure
the forms are all the same and all of
that is is uniform then again I think
that's something Charlie could probably
do regulatory before did you want
to so but I think we should take we
should take the size of the operation as
a separate item and let that deal
with thank you I would I would suggest
that not to put it on the lottery but
have the locations to a committee let's
say five people that select the
Charities you write who they are we you
know the lottery can dictate who should
be on there um and then we keep minutes
example done on a COR will be just a
thought and we just submit it I I mean
certainly it would make sense if a
uniform process Statewide um
and have it be done through Ru making so
that it has the force a law I mean that
does make a lot of sense one of the
difficulties is going to be with the
addition of and I don't disagree with
the logic of having a room that say
makes $250,000 a a week having four
Charities versus two that does increase
our workload as well as the operator's
workload so um and I we talk about doing
that as a separate outside outside of
the five recommendations I mean
certainly as you can imagine when we do
Ru making we always SE public input and
if there's a committee set up by the
operators that wants to have input we
obviously you know when we did Ru making
for historic horse R in the first place
I think we took 47 meetings uh so it's
not as if we did we ignored it was very
much so the B would just be that have
Lottery look at it any needed ruem right
so I did have a thought on that too I
think it's unnecessary because you're
allowed to give Charities up to 10 days
and there's two a day so you can easily
take a small charity and you know we've
partnered with some in the past where
they get 3 days and that's because we
feel their need fits those amount of
days so I think it's definitely in the
purview of the property and if we did
say you have to have a committee and you
put that thought into it on how many
days they're getting and why yeah that's
really not the the logic isn't that
you're you you using a bad process it's
just you're not using the same process
everyone else is exactly and so the the
difficulty is a uniform process so at
least that's the foundation for the
start of a uniform application which we
don't have so okay and it's really hard
to predict like what they're going to
make in the
week up and down the rumors that are
coming online are much much larger and
they're going to have other issues and
candidly aren't here um you know neither
of them are here so those two facilities
will equal what is now in existence in
the state they'll quite double the
capacity so um it's worth it where the
review so the second point on this this
this one is going to be that we should
have some uh rules uh for uniformity of
process for a selection of of uh
Charities uh and that now when when
you're developing the rules you'll
you'll publicly announce that or you
would let yeah the Charities know the uh
the facilities know if they want to
participate in that discussion yeah I
mean as it works now because the Lottery
Commission is actually a commission we
have public hearings even before there's
rulemaking and so our body has to
approve it before it even gets to a jail
car different from other agencies so you
you would reach out you would reach out
to all the facilities to say hey we're
doing the rules on this it all affects
all of you uh all the
facilities I think I just heard vals
resignation
but
oh I was wondering why you were speaking
so freely about
she's still here she's still here good
she's still here um yeah so yes it would
be very much a public process and it
would not be quick I mean it wouldn't be
rule making itself as you all are well
aware it takes you know months not weeks
then eventually 18 Min right and then it
winds up in jail car yeah and then the
jail car there's always the public input
the HHR rules were right contentious
jail car all right sorry Mr chairman if
right right but what what I think I hear
G saying is that I think the uh the
various facilities probably have a lot
of ideas on this one and that before you
even do that that they'd like to meet
and and and throw some ideas to help
help you guys out yeah no it's also when
to get consensus it's we're looking for
the super majority not unanimity right
well you're never going to get 100% un
you know I'm trying here but this is
hard so um okay I think we got I think
we got those one set good ideas good
discussion uh when it comes to the um Mr
chairman yes yeah I think the waiting
list is also one of the items to kind of
put in there that there should be some
published waiting list so that you don't
have a charity if you want on 10 10
different would anybody object to that
because I have I'm asked this all the
time people call me and say well which
charity has a date there's no central
place for that people to go to find out
who's got dates available uniquely I
think this ties into the municipality
piece where our like in Nasha they're
very happy because we we do help out
like the NASA soup kitchen so it's not
like a first in line you get a turn
especially because you have to determine
how many days the charity gets based on
their needs I think it's important to
leave that partnership to give back to
the community that you're hosting in so
I don't I don't think like a one big
waiting list well that's that's part of
that's a good suggestion if you want
Community it's a tearing there's going
to be a tearing what who who's the top
priority who's the next
priority if if I would just oppose the
one waiting list for the whole state I
think like you have a waiting list but I
don't think it's like a first in line
sort of deal you look at the need what
they need who they are you don't want
people just building nonprofits and like
signing up and then getting their turn
and line type of thing just to get the
money you want to put thought into their
cause their mission their programs does
it make sense to part partner
together again the whole state doesn't
have locations you know a lot of the
North Country really isn't covered um go
ahead dick
um well it's a good discussion of a
difficult problem uh and one aspect of
it is what I would call fairness and uh
being able to
participate on equal footing with with
all others and uh the the truth of the
matter is that the big casinos are being
developed right on the bottom
bottom edge of uh this state and um if
you're
up in uh Berlin or other towns uh far
away um from
casinos they won't
um be considered
when the local casino the big Casino you
know is is trying to reach out and be
helpful to the local soup kitchen cuz
they're not local they're up there and
um and that's not going to change I mean
we've got for one thing we've got a
moratorium uh for another it's just the
market and U and yet the money is uh
pouring into these facilities and how
can we reach for fairness so
that um
so of those who are otherwise in have
equal needs can be um have an equal
place in the game and
um uh in looking at one of these charts
that I got maybe at the beginning of
this process or maybe before we began
this process that
shows charity Revenue by month uh it
just struck me that uh on the very first
page you got the American Legion posts
you got about 20 of them
and uh on this page one of them is into
his is getting historic horse racing
revenues getting more money than anybody
else and um another page has the BFW and
uh in the same picture my own town
actually that post got lucky and they're
getting uh uh historic horse racing or
maybe they were quick on their feet I
don't really know um and uh and the
others are not so you know they're sort
of the same thing they're obviously very
different and each one would be proud of
how of their differences but uh uh it's
a big issue and and it used to be not
such a big issue because there wasn't as
much money everything was sort of small
time and local in a sense right now we
got a lot of money and it becomes a
different responsibility for us as a
state than it was before right actually
in my in my other list that we're going
to get to start today anyway hopefully
um one of the things I I when it came to
the number of facilities I put a
caveat I said you know we have the 19
but the caveat was
location you know do we want to make an
exception to somebody up north because
we know where they did a nice job of
putting on the on in their report where
all the locations were clearly up north
you know what if what if Lincoln wanted
to open one or whatever
um I know Co I know you've been
fighting your town which is Littleton
Littleton uh but but but you know if we
if it's I think somehow when these rul
making we have to consider Charities up
north to say that we need to have a
certain percentage or something that we
we we providing coverage to other
Charities not just the ones that are in
the Southern Tier
because you know because you're right
they all the big ones were opening South
for logical reasons I mean they're all
opening down here and I think the
disparity in the need the northern the
northern counties the Northern
Communities and I give you an
example give you an example trate the
community action program that Services
the North country has desperate needs
Transportation needs housing needs
feeding needs that are much different
than the needs that occur in the South
and where are all the facilities the all
of the facilities are gravitating to the
South but by the time it's over and and
uh I I I wonder who's who who will be
taking over whom in the final analysis
but where is the action clearly what
spectrum told us is if you want to
expand you do the following things and
you get closer to the Massachusetts
border because that's where the people
are and that's where the activity takes
place
so the point equitable distribution for
Charities the Charities of the north
have extreme needs and and we we can't
answer those I mean try to answer those
needs through general fund
Appropriations but but indeed that that
isn't happening so I mean the like the
Conway situation I can understand that I
lived in Conway I I know what the needs
in kway are there's the very very rich
in kway and the very very poor in cway
so you're going to address maybe some of
some of those needs but equality in
terms of addressing need is going to
become the issue because the pot is
growing it's just growing by virtue of
of of the fact that that more people are
participating in the in the game but as
the pot grows those who are who are in
in the area that are close are going to
get more they're there they got in there
early what about the people in the North
or other the people at that that have
the need that that's becoming a a that's
becoming a significant concern I would
think the not for-profits would be
concerned about that and certainly from
your standpoint that's got to be a
concern and and remember that that we as
a state we have made these opportunities
more
attractive longer hours 8:00 in the
morning to 4:00 in the evening uh talked
talked about we've increased we've
increased the BET we've done a lot of
other things here to to make it a better
situation for the investor all right I
I'm not opposed to that but but indeed
when you're addressing the need the need
there is glaring need that isn't being
addressed now now do you bring the pot
so that some of it goes that way I I
don't know I do think that's going to
have to be addressed in in the future
because as the facilities grow and as
they gravitate to the southern part of
the state that's where the that's where
it's going to happen thank you Mr JJ you
had a question I will mention like we
definitely have statewide Partners like
for sure but I'm saying if the Nashville
soup kitchen comes I know that's like a
community need like in Nasha of course
we're going to partner with them for an
example if the front door agency Family
Promise of Southern New Hampshire of
course we're going to want to partner
with them but we have have statewide
Partners 100% and everybody has that
option that selection but I do think
it's important much to the municipality
piece I mean we saw the Spectrum report
The Operators technically it's not all
tax but it's the highest in the nation
as it is so at 45% so the Charities are
doing great and I think it's a good
thing and I think it's great we went
from one to two even though some of the
rooms some of the Charities probably
make less than the to make on the
smaller rooms for sure but you know
we're at the point that we've evened out
ours made less in the beginning as well
which was a hard discussion to have with
them but I totally hear what you're
saying I don't disagree I just think if
we want to help the community that the
operators are actually operating out of
and give back I think it's it's okay
to select
them I don't think it should be you know
same with grants in the state like I
don't understand why some of the grants
go and I don't know why they're divided
the way they are when I'm on through
nonprofit boards I don't get any
transparency on where the money is or
where it goes so I'm I'm supportive of
the transparency of a committee this is
how we select them this is how many days
they're getting this is why but I think
it's an overreach to demand that you're
giving to certain areas or certain
Charities I I I don't think I'm not
talking about it to me I'm just talking
about the recognizing of need and and in
recognizing need if there not an entity
in place that can address that need
somehow some way it's either a general
fund
appropriation or or there's a mechanism
in place whereby you share the wealth
that's all I agreed with the need I
think the need's always going to for the
nonprofit sector it always outweighs
what you have so I think for this one we
we decided that
that um that we're going to we're going
to we're going to push this off to
rules and uh and that there'll be
notices out when the rule creation
process begins and that the all of the
facilities will be
notified that that we're going to start
this process and you can all input at
that point in time it's kind of like
kicking the down the road a little here
but I think that's for time purposes no
November 1 is around is coming upon us
so um so for this one I think
um
um uniform process okay so we're
addressing the first one the commission
shall examine how Charities are selected
and whether a uniform process should
exist right now we know it's the local
Chari uh facilities and most have people
like Gia who
uh is in charge of selecting their the
Charities that come before them uh and
just a I'm not in charge I actually
don't even typically vote on it we have
a committee and I
present all of the Charities that have
applied you know for the past two years
and I can make recommendations but we
have a committee that what I meant to
say then is that seems like each of
these facilities has a charity
coordinator type position position oh oh
absolutely to help guide them through
the paperwork make sure everything's
good I do do that I do do that I correct
you just said I was in charge of
selecting them so I wanted to no okay
clarify so so but so the the question on
the table and the the the other piece
which is the amount and increasing the
number of Charities through some other
process I think that has to be a
separate commission to do that CU that
that's going to be to see here in this
conversation but but to get some
uniformity of the of how things are
currently going in terms of of how who
how the Charities are
selected uh we're looking at a um rules
doing that and with the
input
um without additional leg legislation
are you saying that that this is
something Lottery can already do
so I think if I if I can clarify so I
think there's two pieces right so the
first piece again how they're selected
they're selected locally we I don't
think we make any recommendation to that
change of how the charity is selected
locally um and then the second piece is
the process in which they use and that
process can be uniformed and can be done
through rules with
lottery I think that's the and but the
question is we don't need legislation to
do that correct both those things would
not need legislation ones and no you're
a jail car guy so I'm asking question
really and Charlie do you feel you've
got what you need for what's been talked
about I do but realize that the the the
process will be process heavy not sub
substantive heavy if that makes sense
like we'll get a uniform process but it
won't be picking winners and losers it
won't say this charity or that charity
has value versus not value or a tearing
system I don't expect to do that at all
just I mean literally this is the first
step of uniform processes that's what I
I I was going to say I think that is a
reasonable First Step yeah exactly right
okay so so let's um let's vote on this
then
um um local charities we're not we're
not changing that local charities are
going to continue to uh to facilities uh
childood Gaming facilities are going to
continue to pick their um
Charities but at the same time we're
going to create um some additional rules
around that to get a little more
uniformity uh and that will be through
Lottery and and all of the facilities
will be notified as that process
begins um so with that um all in favor
of that say I I
opposed and
no he abstains s jumping up and down now
now now the other so this this covers
the things on this list but um of the of
the of the
statute but but I'm also we'll be also
recommending and you'll see when I for
our next meeting I'm going to write some
of this up and then we can all see the
language but I'll I'll add to that
asking for another commission to address
the larger issue of how much is enough
you know is 15,000 to that to be you
know that and
then how do we how do we deal with the
growth when it comes to the revenues
going to the Charities and how much how
much revenue should be should there be
ceiling no ceiling you know all of that
so we we I'll have language that we can
we can vote on then so the second piece
we have a half hour left so I want to go
to this other document that I I sent out
what I tried to do was to
summarize some of the things from the
report and other things from
the uh from from our
meetings um I want to start I want to go
to the bottom of this list I'm not going
to go in any particular order here but
I'm going to see what we can accomplish
in the next half
hour uh now uh our AG is not
here uh so number
24 should we have a waiver this was on
page 43 of the spectrum report it was
they didn't really make recommendations
they made suggestions I would call it
should we have a waiver of of
qualification for institutional
investors holding their ownership
interest in publicly traded companies
for Passive investment purposes only I
think we hold on that one until we have
um the the assistant AG here uh in the
next meeting but the one the next one
should we have a regulatory scheme for
licensing the vendors who conduct with
our charity charitable Gaming facilities
and this is the way he phras the phrase
that it's little award and Supply gaming
with our charal Gaming facilities and
Supply gaming equipment and other
related services so what that means
is do we want to do we want to charge a
fee it seems like the industry Norm is
that to regulate the machine
manufacturers that are here in the state
the totalizer company I guess as well it
seems like others do charge a fee for
this uh so that you know Charlie just
left but um it it seems like this
something might be appropriate that we
we um have a recommendation around
this uh that we
actually do something uh to charge a fee
to to help offset the regul rate of
Regulation costs of Lottery to to
monitor these these
things so discussion on that one it's
a because again the only the only the
only fee that's charged is
$750 a year which is another one of my
bullets here by the
way I I I don't know where it is here
now
but to me you
know I guess there were some some some
states didn't have any fee at all and
but we and there's clearly no entry fee
for for new Charities to come in um
and um it just seems to me that well
let's discuss it I mean am IA the only
one that thinks it may be appropriate to
to tr charge a license fee I think
Charlie in one meeting said he he he
would would consider
that
um
um she left too all right uh so so okay
now I'm speechless so no no no comment
on it I I think it's something we have
to look at look at uh as the original
sponsor of the gaming legislation we
assessed a very substantial fee uh to
get to get a license and we had we
developed a program of how those how
those revenues would be dispensed to to
the state to the local communities and
to to uh anyone who was involved in in
the process now
the 700 I don't know where the $750 came
from but but it's a bit whacked in my
opinion uh so that's something we have
to look at and look at the uh the work
that now goes to the Lottery Commission
and and what has to what has to be done
there does the $750 cover that charie is
he still here or is he out Charlie step
out he stepped out well I mean
there there's there there's got to be a
uh there's got to be some thought given
given here uh about that it's about the
tears if you have a facility that's this
large should they be paying a a fee a a
smaller facility should they be paying
aisy it's got to be a graduated scale
and we we kind of created a graduated
scale when we said more than one
facility would be put in place but I I
think I I believe it's something that
that has to be that has to be looked at
U
and there from what we gathered from
Spectrum there's nothing but growth here
this thing is growing and and as it
grows it'll become more complicated to
deal with from a from a regulation level
as I say we got one situation that has
developed which is going to go on it
seems to be forever
if they don't if they if that that isn't
settled then then I I I think what we're
talking about is it doesn't have any
relevance and I I I don't think we're
talking about an entry fee at this point
U because the 19 up to 19
facilities all would have entered in the
old all even if we had an entry fee uh
there was no entry fee and it wouldn't
be fair to anybody new having to pay you
know $100,000 200 thou 300,000 million
to to come in here it's just not right
because they'd have to amortize it it
wouldn't you know they probably wouldn't
come but um so I just talking about the
the annual fee and I think they should
be maybe tiered for the smaller place
would be less the bigger places should
be
more um and you know maybe the smaller
places keep the 750 but the bigger
places we're talking about more so
that's what we're talking about Charlie
I I you know that um that's number one
and the other should there be a fee to
the vendors of the the the machine
manufacturers probably the to in our
case the totalizer companies for doing
business in New Hampshire which seems to
be a common practice in other
states if I didn't unless I misheard
what spectrum was saying that let's
start with that one I mean do we want to
even have anything in the report about
this is my question to everybody I
personally think we should but I can be
our voted here on this one yeah U thank
you Mr chairman the first people in paid
a certain fee anybody that wants to come
in now has a lot more data to go by
because the risk for the first group of
people coming in was higher than a risk
from somebody coming in now somebody
coming and now can look at the whole
state where can I put my Casino how much
can I expect to make I think their risk
is higher at the very beginning when
there were no casinos it was rolling a
dice we're going to sink a lot of money
in here are we going to make it or not I
just think there's
more educated or uh data out there now
for somebody to come in and chose pay
any dollar you're saying other other
things but they didn't pay any dollar
entry fee to be here
that's what I'm talking about an entry
fee but I'm not and again I'm not
suggesting that we do an entry fee
because it's too late I mean the do
door's been wide open for a long time
and everybody's walked through it it's
never too late so we made it very
attractive whether we knew it or not
basically it was very attractive to come
here so
um so that one I'm not talking about I'm
talking about the the annual fees to to
again the r renewal renewal license fees
start with that one the renewal license
fees 750 bucks a
year you know so I mean the brook the
nashille place the the now the propos
the the the ones that Lou rattled off
the larger
places that's chump change
$750 um is is that cover any why do we
have license fees in the first place you
used to be in ways and means we used to
talk about it covering the cost of
Regulation now in in Lottery's
case it you know it comes out of the net
what the state gets is the net of the
after expenses you know the state gets
their their portion of the
revenues Charlie Pays His expenses out
of that and then whatever is left it's
just like like liquor goes to the
state so it's a little bit different but
um
but so in in reality that they the
percentage that the state gets from the
from the gross Gaming revenue is
covering expenses I understand that but
it just seems to me that there should be
$750 just a suggestion
um I think we're a little bit in the
dark here we don't know the cost of of
Regulation right as we sit here and um
yet it seems likely that $750 isn't
covering that cost um but uh if we could
go through if we could specify in
response to this question this item that
uh we Rec we we recommend that a process
be established I don't know whether the
legislation is needed for this or not to
review
the sufficiency of the fee structure to
support the cost of Regulation something
like that um at least we get off the
dime here and uh have recognized that
there's something that needs to be
looked at so and you know we just talked
with uh on the previous issue about uh
setting up going through a regulatory
process that relates to the regulation
of this system that we've got here and
uh that's going to cost money um but do
we add into that then the number 25 uh
the the
uh equipment manufacturers yeah right
and the and the total lator people and
that could be a part of the review
process and any new uh fees that uh
might might be I'm trying to be all
inclusive in this commission it's you
know that we at least discussed it yeah
um so again I go back to a reminder in
the in the Spectrum report they talk
about where the highest tax rate of any
state in revenue for here and I I look
at as
Aames right but I looked at as a
short-term versus long-term play right
so I think the fees The Upfront fees and
well I agree with you on things like
number 23 which talk about the
background investigation fees and maybe
we we can do a similar thing to um the
the uh renewal fees to be that an actual
cost re recoup of an actual cost so some
renewal may be simple because the
investigate they the operator turns in
all the pieces of paper they're all
correct right at the first time it's
literally just a review and and a stamp
others like okay I got questions on this
and I got questions on this and I got
questions on this and I've got a three
days worth more of work that I have to
do to go get the ant Chase those down so
I would be okay with the variable rate
that that deals with actual cost because
remember I think we have a con we have a
a a Supreme Court case that talks about
fees have to be result of either
function of
regulation which I think we take care of
in our taxes or the functional actual
effort which is the renewal process and
what that the effort is needed and that
they have to be they have to match they
can't be a money-making Revenue they
have to be the explain costs of the
state um and so I would be okay with a
variable rate for renewals that deals
with the actual effort right and the
same with the investigation cap here
that variable rate that deals with um
it's for the actual cost of what it is
if it's done against the operator does
all the work up front and it's all nice
and clean Charlie that his staff has to
go over it they have no questions
whatsoever and they approve it that's
going to be a lot less than someone who
turned in half an application has a
whole bunch of extra work um and they
and Lottery has to do a whole bunch of
more work to do that so that fee for
that person who didn't do all their
upfront work should be hired right we I
remember in Ways and Means we've had
these issues come up before about about
those that do a good job of of so people
Charlie uh they pretty much know how to
do it what to do is is that is that just
a is that much of a problem for you so
Val the folks who actually renew their
right so that's not a big issue um how
long has the um 50
$750 renewal fee been in place again how
long has there a
place it's
before it's before we absorbed racing so
it's been there since
Lottery okay so just I mean at the most
basic level inflation
adjusted number probably needs to happen
um and then I would also agree that the
larger the establishment
the more work there's going to be done
by the state there there may need to be
a sliding scale based on size maybe
based on square footage something like
that
appointment somebody just complexity of
ownership too yeah so so there may be
some I mean at the most basic level
maybe we recommend a higher fee for now
but obviously further studies needed to
know exactly um how a sliding scale
would would operate should be some kind
of a sliding scale we'll say and and the
recommendation in that um
um I want to give it to you the
legislature has to deal with that so
right so should we make a recommendation
the legislature that we
yeah legisl to was meat or something to
yeah it would come that okay why don't
we do it that way so we'll punt to the
legislature on that to come up with
something but it's a recommendation that
we think that we should all right that's
the basic
fee why don't we handle that one first
so so the recommendation is that it's
been a while since we've looked at the
$750 fee uh with the with the places
with the CH uh the facilities growing in
size should uh the question of should
there be a variable fee structure uh be
put in place yes
certainly um Revenue estimates for just
HHR for the next year are the state's
going to yield 26 million I didn't hear
that I'm sorry so that our Revenue
estimates for the next fiscal year for
HHR is that we're going to yield 26 Mill
to the state which more than covers the
cost of Regulation so if you factor that
in is I know and that's why I caveat
that earlier that it was you it's
different than any other thing because
they generate
revenue and it what goes to the state is
the net so if Charlie feels he needs
more well again any any additional staff
you would have to get approval from the
legislature it's kind of a Kind 22 just
just to uh following
your uh the information $6 million for
HHR in uh the coming year next fiscal
year do you have a number for this
I put some context so
um I did this math just
recently charitable gambling revenue is
up 46% year-over-year 23
24 um so for this coming year I think we
had plugged in 26 million again for
short course racing
there are a couple facilities which are
planned but I
fear construction being what it is I'm
always fear of planning on places that
aren't open yet yeah right and so it's
26 million again in the next fiscal year
25 yeah but I I would expect that to be
low I would expect to exceed 30 sounds
like you're being conservative on that
yeah which is fine because we don't know
if there could be construction delays or
delays in the approval so is your
question now the question we're on now
um the we're going to leave as a
variable left to the legislature to
figure out how to make that work right
but on the I'm going to break these into
two questions so in the fee relative to
the third party yeah let's can we just
stay at the fee you're you're going to
the equipment manufacturers is the next
one that's right I think we should have
a separate a separate one on that so so
in terms of the basic fee that exists
today the 750 uh we're going to say to
the
legislature um please take a look at
that fee to see if a variable fee makes
more sense going forward given that the
size of some of these facilities is much
greater do do okay that's that's my
motion uh I so all in favor that say
please say yes I yes I no any he knows
Charlie D stain okay you can do the work
all right so then the what really is 25
it has to do with the licensing of
vendors the equipment vendors
and and the totalizer
people um I throw that open it was it
was stated in the report that that's the
common practice I thought it's worthy of
us to
discuss um again again Lottery gets
plenty of revenue from from the their
proceeds but um is there something that
we think is worthy because you do do we
monitor we let's talk to let's talk to
manufacturers what what what's our
oversight responsibility with the
manufacturers of the of the uh historic
racing machines so we
don't we don't license or or approve of
the manufacturers but their equipment
and math models are submitted for our
approval uh with a certification from a
lab uh and the lab generally is GLI
which is gaming Laboratories
Incorporated uh which is the gold
standard of test labs and so the
equipment is tested and verified it's
just not we don't approve the company
itself
right um so that's verified a
bit but okay so you do you feel it's
Lottery speaking for
lottery um that that we these vendors
should be licensed forget about a fee
for a minute should these these vendors
be licensed with the
state I mean certain there's no harm in
it it is extra work obviously because
these yeah it yeah should they license
yes they should okay but they shouldn't
be um no they should be licensed yeah
all right how about how about the
totalizer people I mean ultimately we
should probably make it so that every
gaming vendor in the state is is
licensed right so everyone who provides
gaming material whether it be tables
machines um should be licensed and then
the question regarding non-gaming
vendors you know if they if you know
Supply bread or you know roast beef I
don't think those folks list gaming
gaming related so
discussion I me so I know we haven't
talked about this it came up in the
report that's all that's why I'm
bringing it up so I'm going to go back I
tend to be against that idea and again
the reason being is we're getting our
Revenue I don't what Charlie's approving
these through GLI that the functionality
so the question comes we don't we don't
charge Ford to bring cars in Hampshire
we charge a dealer for when they sell
cars in New Hampshire um we don't charge
the manufacturer money right so I don't
know why we would possibly do this if
we're already validating the information
we're getting our revenue from the
machines already that are in the state
um so I I guess I'm still struggling is
what's the value to the manufacturer
other than they get to put their
machines in the Hampshire um what is New
Hampshire providing as a regulatory uh
structure not doing anything right it's
being evaluated by another organization
right so again there's no value to a
license in New Hampshire other than I
get to put my machine here just like
Ford gets to put their car of the
dealers um and I just don't know why we
would license that what what the
function what is the state interest in
licensing it if we're already getting
certified Labs from the gold standard
lab that the machine is functional for
the state um and functional for use
Nationwide um what what's the value to
Hampshire why do we do it other than
just to create revenue and yet no to me
that's not a
reason all right so I tend to agree with
you Tim on this one actually but I bring
it up because it was in the report that
was in the report that
we um I mean we could say that we
discuss this and that at this time we
don't think it's necessary step to take
is everybody okay with
so unless you make a compelling argument
Charlie that at this point can you live
without it well of course yeah I mean
it's not as if that then the world will
fall
obviously the machines are tested and
certified for equipment like if the
manufacturers want to move equipment
they have to get our approval so it's
not as if there's no regulation it's
just the standard practice in the
industry is to have gaming vendors
licensed in
state so I don't know that's not I don't
think that's compelling at least with
you
folks
well I'll say okay we we could just keep
it neutral for now um in the report that
we discussed it um I agree with that
keep it neutral no recommendation on
this one okay so uh all all in favor of
saying that we we keep things the way
they are related to this issue uh say I
I anybody opposed
okay yeah your extion really came
through on this
one let's go to
23 um the backup investigation fees
Captain then I know our Assistant
Attorney General weighed in on this
at last meeting I won't speak well I
guess I'm speaking for him um he thought
that it it should be whatever those fees
are uh this is for new people
entering in our Market uh that those
investigation fees should not be capped
at 5,000 they should be
unlimited does anybody agree or disagree
with that statement I agree I agree with
that in most of our legislation we never
had cap it was what cost and that they
pay the total fees that's always been
the the basic premise of how we
investigate how we investigate people so
I don't know I don't where did the
$5,000 limit go through I don't know he
gave the RSA 287d 11 Roman
4 so um okay so we we we'll make a
recommendation that the
legislature I just Mr chair one question
um is there any um I mean obviously it
makes sense for the cost to be covered
but at the same time does this open the
door for I don't know an agency who
doesn't want to see somebody come in
potentially say well we're still
investigating now we have to do this I
you know I don't know I I think we've I
remember in Ways and Means we've had
these discussions before but and I can't
remember now what um where all the fees
are paid so I think there's precedent
for other other areas not just in
lottery for this
and I think di was saying I mean u l you
was saying that right that there's
precedent for this yes okay well it's
been pres in numerous pieces of
legislation that have been brought
forward that the total cost will be
paid and I I I could I me agree you you
can say that there a cause concern but I
think that have confidence in the fact
that the guys who are doing
investigation are doing the
investigation and we're not we're not
overdoing it
you got to have some trust in
that so there is the recommendation is
that the legislature will take a look at
RSA 287d colon
11 Roman
4 which caps the $5,000 to take the cap
away and make it uh a fee based on the
actual cost of doing the
investigation okay any other discussion
on that so just a quick uh recommend
that be in our report say I I I anybody
oppose
abstain
okay all right I'm going to go we have
five eight minutes left on my watch
let's go to some of the easier ones for
now we're going to reconvene in two
weeks
um so let's go to number
10 shall we allow Casino credit no yeah
that's that's my that's if we're going
to be yeah none of our gaming platforms
do we allow credit as a matter of policy
like our draft KS or ey Lottery even
though there's no l law against it it's
just bad policy so I would be right and
if we're going to call ourselves
chatable gaming I don't think we want to
open this up I think you got a consensus
yeah pretty good I'm I'm just a chair
just asking the questions okay so we uh
so the recommendation is going to be no
uh no
credit be a
recommendation from the committee uh all
all okay with that just say no if you're
not
okay uh should we allow 24-hour
operation um no I would say no too uh
even even would do we open it to 3 o' we
just
expanded and even at that do we know do
we know how many are actually going out
the four I I I don't I'm not aware of
anybody going out the four don't think
I no I mean that point you're get
staffing issues right right and it's
just it just it just doesn't make sense
to to be open that late um also I I
think that's under the name of
charitable gaming that we we keep it we
keep I think we just recommend that the
current the current hours of
operation uh as in current statute is
fine is that okay all right you'll see
my words on this
um the the one that's going to be a
little a
little well oh yeah number six that's
another simple one thank you uh shall we
allow complimentary alcohol no NOP right
all right hey good we're all on the same
page right the one that's going to have
a little discussion let's started here
is the um should we should we have
pulled
tips so let's this and this will be the
last one of the of the day yeah so again
I I think that New Hampshire has a
pretty good tipping law I don't think we
should be changing it and messing with
it especially for an industry specific
change um and I think you know New
Hampshire is a big believer you eat what
you kill if you work and you earn the
money you get to keep your money and not
have to give it to share it with
somebody else so yeah um so I'd be
inclined to not recommend pooling tips
even though I understand that there's a
whole area of uh you know the argument
is that it's pooling tips reduces the
risk of corruption um and collusion with
the dealer um but I don't see that
happening in New Hampshire we have
security measures in place The Operators
are watching it um so I don't see this
as being um a good answer and never mind
the fact that's a Workforce issue that
there are people from Massachusetts that
come up and from other states that come
up and work in the Hampshire because we
don't fool our tips and they get the the
amount of money they earn they actually
get the keep so so I would not be
inclined in any way shape or form to
touch this well there's there's no
indication that we've got a problem
right that we're trying to solve I guess
there another way to look at it um and
it was the fellow from New Jersey who
that was the the the uh he headed up the
casinos in Atlantic City or something
whatever he was he said what yeah that
could possibly be collusion between the
dealer and the and the
player uh but
I don't know um you know we do I mean
all have cameras they're all being
watched uh and I don't know is it how
easy is it to identify uh hanky panking
going on I mean would they we could
tell I mean as you can imagine the
operator is more interested in that
almost than we are like because it's
their money too right and so yeah the
the levels of security and the cameras
and the surveillance and the Dual the
segregation of Duties and the
all or internal controls like their
internal controls processes is submitted
to us for approval their surveillance is
submitted to us for approval so it's
it's not impossible but it's very very
very hard and both of us have a vested
interest in making sure it doesn't
happen so not saying it's never happened
it's just rare incidents obviously when
people and cash are together there's
always a problem but it's not as if it's
extraordinary in our industry right and
the one thing Mr chair is again it's
already permissible to pull tips but New
Hampshire requires it be un unanimous
that all everybody agrees to do it if
one person steps out then that's no
longer we can let we can let it's
already permissive right we don't we're
just question is whether we're going to
mandate it or not right yeah so and I
say no we don't mandate so right now the
individual facilities can figure that
out the
employees okay you had a yeah thank you
Mr chairman we've seen a tipping Bill
come in maybe a dozen times since I've
been in the legislature and every year
that people show up and say no I want to
keep my own tips I earn my tips I want
to keep
them okay well I think I think we got an
answer
here um so I'll just say that um we are
not going to recommend uh pooling of
tips is that anybody disagree with that
NOP okay so all right we are now at our
2hour limit um just to be respectful so
I'm going to
suggest another I'm going to try to
write what we've discussed today in
short
little things that we could see the
words we can we can do a a formal vote
on each one of those as and eventually
we're going to have to have the whole
report so we have a whole other list of
things to talk about um uh next meeting
I'd like to do that on SE two weeks from
now September
30th is that okay with everybody can you
look check September 30th and the
question
is uh we go back to
Lottery do we know if the room is
available well if it's not I'll confirm
today okay all right I will confirm
today right we just had today we had
folks an entire vendor community of ours
com from Israel so oh um it's hard to
rebook them from that's fine that's fine
Lottery unless otherwise just check your
emails on if we find out that's not a we
will we'll get it out there in bold
print that we're meeting here U meeting
there U meeting here instead all right
well thank you everybody uh this has
been productive um and I'll have some
some stuff for us to review next time
but we'll keep on going down the list